[Musique]
washington résonnent au son des tambours
une fois de plus des américains sont
dans la rue pour défendre leurs acquis
le droit à l'avortement qui est de
nouveau remise en question
les vouant résonner dans 600 villes du
pays
aliot thompson crains qu'il n'y ait plus
de séparation entre l'église et l'état
si les gens ne peuvent pas se faire
avorter dit elle ils vont le faire quand
même et risquent de mourir
partout les manifestants scandent le
même slogan my body my choice mon corps
mon choix
et puis il y à l'autre son de cloche
nous sommes vendredi soir et ces jeunes
pris devant une clinique d'avortement
mon corps mon choix dit il ce n'est pas
leur corps à n'ont pas le droit de tuer
un autre être humain c'était pas le
corps de la femme c'est le corps de dieu
ils ont à peine 20 ans et sont persuadés
d'avoir la science infuse ou plutôt la
bénédiction divine
[Musique]
on ne veut pas contrôler le corps de la
femme dit ravie elle si une femme avait
une amygdalite où se faisait enlever
quoi que ce soit ça nous est égal la
seule raison pour laquelle nous sentons
interpellés c'est parce qu'il s'agit
d'une vie humaine une fois
nous faisons avec amour distille on doit
sauver un être humain et pas d'exception
pour les cas de viol ou d'inceste
quelle que soit la façon dont une
personne a été conçue dit il a la droit
à la vie
on ne résout pas un crime en commettant
un autre dit celle ci
ces jeunes de l'union des étudiants
catholiques sont en quelque sorte les
porte drapeaux des conservateurs qui ont
le vent en poupe en floride avec à la
tête du gouvernail le très conservateur
gouverneur du land de santis surnommé
deux minutes chaume il est pro vie mais
quand il s'agit de vaccins contre lacko
vide il prône le choix personnel des
citoyens il appuie le représentant
républicain barnaby webster qui vient de
déposer un projet de loi sur
l'avortement similaire à celui du texas
où l'interruption de grossesse sera
interdite dès la sixième semaine sous
peine d'une amende de 10000 dollars pour
les médecins
je trouve que ce que le texas a fait et
brillant dit lindeberg qui a fait du
mouvement pro vie son cheval de bataille
elle espère que la floride suivra le
modèle texan
week end baby
chaque journée on peut sauver des bébés
en floride dit elle est une bonne
journée pour l'état hayder voilà à la
clinique planned parenthood de tala si
on frémit à l'idée de voir l'état à
intervenir
l'idée que des politiciens vont
s'ingérer dans des décisions médicales
privées plus que dérangeant de cet
accord le ring brendle et la directrice
de l'organisation
ce ne sera pas juste un problème pour la
floride ou tel mais pour tous les états
du sud est qui ont déjà un accès très
limité avec la loi au texas on voit déjà
des patientes venir non seulement de
l'alabama mais de la georgie de la
louisiane et aussi du texas et quant à
sa prochaine
c'est un sérieux pas en arrière dit sous
massa qui ne pensait jamais de voir
manifester en 2021 pour défendre le
droit à l'avortement
un droit acquis en 1973 après le célèbre
arrêt roe contre wade ou la cour suprême
garantissez le droit des femmes
d'avorter jusqu'à 22 semaines si
aujourd'hui la cour suprême invalide cet
arrêt chaque état pourrait interdire ou
autoriser les avortements avec six juges
conservateurs et trois libéraux cette
hypothèse n'est plus écartée
wright healy à une guerre sur mon corps
dit cette étudiante lors de son discours
de fin d'année rights of the enders
on ne peut pas rester silencieuse tels
que
les voies vont continuer à raisonner
dans les rues pour défendre le droit à
l'avortement
un combat qui va surtout se jouer devant
les tribunaux et plusieurs espèrent que
joe biden va nommer d'autres juges à la
cour suprême pour amener un certain
équilibre